comme son sourire était doux et son
nez penché bizarrement, il appelait son cœur et courbait une
rangée de toasts, un tas d'ordures. Le duc
de Grummond en a dit autant quand je lui ai lu le
poème le plus ridicule et le plus stupide que j'ai jamais entendu, monsieur, mais quand je lui ai lu
lui ai dit que c'était moi qui l'avais écrit, il a ensuite
changé son ton plein de
sentiments exquis et de majesté pathétique, les nobles
feront tout pour plaire à
leur roi, c'est le système du roi au
sommet des nobles en bas, les garder sous
contrôle nécessite de la discipline, c'est pourquoi
J'ai confié le travail à mon cher frère
Philip, l'étiquette, l'ensemble des règles
indiquant aux nobles comment se comporter, comment
manger, comment boire, comment plier une serviette,
comment s'incliner devant les membres de la
famille royale, comment traiter les membres de la
gent féminine, l'
étiquette.  certains nobles passent des journées entières
à essayer de mémoriser chaque règle et
règlement. Mon frère ne montre aucune pitié envers
ceux qui enfreignent mon vieil ami
le duc de Grama. Quel tour dois-je
lui jouer ensuite ? Je ne mangerais pas une
poire pourrie mais le duc le fera.  j'adore quand je le
lui donne mmm délicieux hmm
toi